what you're about to see is the
culmination of nine hours of work all
these basics and education and learning
recently got an update that added a
secret ending to the game and me I
naively thought that I'd be able to get
it relatively easily considering I'd
already beaten Baldy so how bad could
this secret ending be however in order
to get this ending you have to get every
single question that all the puts in
front of you wrong and some of you may
know that when you answer a question
wrong Baldy gets angry and when baldies
angry he moves faster and faster and
faster which requires new strategies the
utilization of a new character that they
added to this game which makes this
entire thing possible and it requires a
mountain of luck so get ready for a
whole lot of Baldy on the final attempt
that actually succeeded and then
afterwards once you witness the secret
ending you can see a cavalcade a
compilation a collection of all the
worst times that all the spanked my ass
harder than it's ever been spanked
so please enjoy the exact wrong time the
principal just had to be I wasn't even
running
I I was able to beat the bully like I
had enough stuff the bully could just
take something and I'd be okay I think I
[ __ ] myself over because I did the the
lock but either way I was boned no
matter what with that guy there oh my
god are you [ __ ] kidding me I just
can't believe it it's so ridiculous
like of all the people of all the people
and at the exact moment that I couldn't
I just hurts you know it just hurts it
just really hurts
I hate RNG I hate it with a passion this
is a red-hot burning passion I hate it
how are you able to go through like the
middle that doesn't make any sense at
all okay hey buddy how you doing oh that
was rough
but at least I got there that was gonna
be a win if that guy wasn't there that
was 100% going to be a win cuz I had
everything that I needed I wasn't gonna
run I wasn't gonna do anything like I
just had the one if I just had the one
drink like that was really all I needed
but I also got to remember if I'm
pushing them with the soda I can't use
the lock because then they're just gonna
go around the other way and that's gonna
screw me over more than anything that I
could do to myself so I just got to
remember take it easy take it slow use
the lock on the lunchroom wait for him
at the lunchroom door like I have to
wait for him at the lunchroom door
because that really like that's the only
place that I could legitimately get him
and stop him for good I'm gonna see if
this guy yup he's gone okay should be
able to go down to this one
but that was so close though so close
okay he's a GU ssin oh hey buddy why are
you they're all people to be there are
you there oh that's that's Baldy right
there okay thank you for all eternity
all eternity huh wow that's impressive
whoosh well screw me then looks like I'm
not even good in any of them okay I
think he's going back
[Music]
[ __ ] oh he was just about to go around
that corner god dammit I can't get
something else there's the coin that's
good okay I don't know if he saw me
I'm not harmed wasn't sure he might have
lost me but I never know with these
things so hard to tell ah [ __ ]
I almost lost him buddy yeah he was just
going random directions and he just
happened to stumble back upon me oh well
alas should happen no no no I got
schisms got my scissors for you
see let's see if I can do okay god oh no
oh no oh no run no no no friend friend
friend did I make it out of it
I don't know if I got out of it well I
don't think he saw me I think he rounded
the corner just like just just barely as
I was rounding the corner okay
well that's nothing hey I don't like
that song when it's waggling out right
at me
yeah three hours everybody give it up
three hours three hours whoo
okay so this is okay we can kind of
circumvent everything get launched over
here so long as we play keep-away we're
doing okay okay he's gonna lose sight of
me because there's no doors of course
there's a bully here can you please not
be there could you not be there all
right well now he's gonna know
[Music]
there we go okay thank you
are you gonna do it again
[Music]
play this jump or girl I hate her I'm
gonna get this scissors too just in case
you never know with this [ __ ] leave go
oh oh he is there okay schizos okay come
on buddy come on mama drama come on
buddy buddy buddy buddy boo boo buddy
buddy boo bear
buddy buddy boo bear I love you oh no
okay it's fine
buddy buddy boo bear I love you buddy
buddy boo bear okay come on push me push
me push me good push me push me like you
should push me okay all right now that's
enough pushing you you did your job you
did good I'm very proud of you okay he
should lose me he should lose me okay
get the other okay she's saw me god
dammit why did I have to go into the
intersection to be seen why did I have
to do that I didn't have to do that
actually that's something that I did not
have to do and yet I did it why did I
did it I don't know okay whatever I'm
gonna go get the fifth one we're
Oh God every time he's just like oh I
can't get away from him okay
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no I will not okay what am i do if
i can pop around you're just in time
easy there damn easier okay that's fine
you come with me thank you okay it's
better this is better positioning
because what's gonna happen is I'm gonna
be able to round this corner okay should
be able to get around this corner wow I
cannot believe that guy got me not
running and then I'll get all the way
over to the end use use the door once he
gets over there once he comes out the
door real angry like he will know we got
so you probably got swept away okay okay
this is gonna be interesting
okay the guy just went away he's a-comin
I gotta I don't know where he is
but that's okay because he might we
might be able to lose and no I will not
you've done your job good job thank you
for that now I got to do my thing that's
okay buddy don't worry about it you
stressing too much
okay okay
he's gonna see where he goes I think
he's coming to me no no okay
here we go
maybe three sodas would be no I gotta
use it lock I'm gonna use the lock so
I'm gonna do that's the strategy that's
I use the lock that's what I gotta do
when he's right over here where the [ __ ]
goddamnit is he you really oh my god are
you [ __ ] kidding me that's not where
you're supposed to be [ __ ] okay
well we're gonna have to deal with it
like this then huh [ __ ] that's not good
no do not don't why okay you
[ __ ]
this is not ideal but I don't think it's
unwinnable I think I can still get this
if I just play my cards super right cuz
he's gonna be coming down the other side
now it's not what I wanted to do but
it's what I had to do anyway because you
go
duration so I'm gonna try to go the
other way you know what I mean
[Music]
because I think the lock goes away
actually I have no reason to believe
that the lock is not it's the lock still
there isn't it
no it's not okay this is fine okay I've
got okay we're going the other way but I
think it's still gonna be okay
like no matter what at the end of the
day it's just about getting all four I
can get the other soda too okay let's
not get ahead of ourselves okay you got
now we now have get this one
[Music]
I'm not looking at the dude is he coming
down this hallway to the here no he's
not but if that girl gets near me I am
pushing her away
you better both [ __ ] believe okay
areas okay
I've got two sodas I've got two sodas
doing it just because I don't want to
get caught
with the dude there you know what I mean
[Music]
yes finally I did it and it was so clean
it was so clean it was so clean oh I'm
gonna lose I'm gonna lose consciousness
I did it there was such a clean run it
had the clean ear and it was a
magnificent hook so I already knew that
this was the way it is but I didn't see
what was in the office the only thing I
saw was how to get to it what's in the
office is a mystery hey I just man can
you believe that was my first truck just
over nine and a half hours is what that
took let's see what's in the office has
room for improvement go see Baldy in his
office for some tips okay
those lights are a little funky but okay
[Music]
ah nice banana arm okay uh
I wasn't even worth it I wasn't even
worth it that wasn't even remotely worth
it that wasn't even remotely worth nine
and a half hours of work there Owens
ears bleeding I have my volume cranked
up for games like this but oh my god but
we did it I did it we did it you did it
we all did it
I feel awful I feel worse I feel worse
for doing this you know I thought I
thought that uh I thought that uh you
know I'd be like no yeah that's pretty
good I'm pretty happy about all this
turns out now turns out not even a
little bit not at all no nothing turns
out I hate myself kind of a lot I wish I
never even saw this game I wish I never
even knew that there was a secret ending
to this game I wish I wish I had done
something completely different with my
life but that's uh that's what happens
at least I did it so that you guys
didn't have to thank you everybody that
partook of this and join me on this
sorted adventure of futility and death
and thank you everybody that believed in
me so far and I appreciate all of you
being here spread love and joy as much
as you can before Baldy comes and shoves
you stick up your butt and thank you
again for watching and as always I'll
see you in the next video Hey whoa hey
bad touch bad touch class
nor oh they fix the door sploit oh okay
that was a bit too close out in a while
so that's not fair that is really unfair
that's that is unfair do push me push me
push me push me there we go
no no no this way push push this there
we go that's what I call a push all
right oh that's horrible
oh this is bad um well I the principles
right there so again no hug fat hug bad
hug okay there we go I'm gonna pop this
boy he's a good butcher push have that
me you missed you [ __ ] you missed by
that much
oh never mind never mind no not this way
not this oh he took my quarter
he took my quarter damn you please no
principal no oh my soda
[Music]
no but but no you're gonna bug me
get me before he hugs me detention for
you all right okay there we go kill me
kill me please just kill me for you when
will I learn oh my god I
I forgot that bi oh I forgot I didn't
think you'd be that close you believed
in me that's good I don't believe in
myself so I don't even know if it's
gonna work out for me I know I was going
in here anyway oh the tape did nothing
no you were gonna get me oh no no but
the guy I have to run no please I don't
want it missed me by that much okay I've
got I've got soda so I can push you back
oh did I get him I was off target by
just a little bit I'm just sucking it up
majorly oh are you kidding me 30 seconds
detention for you when will you learn oh
yeah he's gonna slap my ass
oh he's gonna oh he's really gonna
Whangdoodle on my ass oh boy here he
comes
yep here comes someone catch me put me
in detention I've been a bad boy I want
to go back I want to go to bad boy place
please please sweeper man okay cool
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna use the
soda I'm gonna blast him down this
hallway I'm gonna turn around I'm gonna
use this soda I'm a blasting down the
hallway
I'm gonna go to the last room I'm gonna
make the long pass around the cafeteria
and three to one God are you [ __ ]
kidding me
are you [ __ ] the one time I'm trying
to whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa God
you gotta believe if you believe in me
type hashtag Marga pliers big belief boy
and you believe you believe in me you
want to be mark blares big belief boy
you know you do I know you do we all
know we know and we do we do and we know
we know and do and we do know and we
know to do it we know and we do we know
and do come on come on come on come on
come on come on let's go let's go let
you know
oh please rescue me rescue me rescue me
rescue me man you are a saint
get out of my way
hi hi I knew it I [ __ ] knew it
you [ __ ] [ __ ] but I don't know is
that yes yes yes yes yeah that was very
almost got me no not the bully not the
bully no anything but the bully anything
but the anything but the bully anything
but the bully not the for light not the
boy
[Music]